Tomlinson: One thing
I found useful was reading
through the SDK documentation
thoroughly,
as well as doing the sample
applications provided,
such as Hello World
and Notepad tutorial.
They are really helpful.
There can be
a lot of information
which is overwhelm--
overwhelming
to first-time developers,
so reading
through the SDK documentation,
even though you have
an understanding,
can be very helpful.
I'd also like to point out
the Apps
for Android project.
Source code
is being provided by Google
to help
first-time developers
overcome any hurdles
they may encounter
while trying to develop
for Android,
as well as having
some cool games on there.